[Music]
[Applause]
Taylor twellman covers soccer former
United States men's national player and
uh analyst for the mothership and uh
kind enough to join us on the program
Taylor thanks for joining us what were
your expectations prior to the match
against Wales for the United States
Dan that's an interesting question
because I think naturally my
expectations before England beat Iran
6-2 was the United States has to beat
Wales in order to advance out of the
group then when that result happened
even more so it was vital that they had
to get three points and here's the
reason why ultimately you do not want to
play Iran in the final game for
geopolitical reasons as one of those
reasons of needing to get three points
to get out of the group and the reason
why is that's going to be the biggest
game in Iran's history they list now in
their histories of federation
1998 the World Cup game against the
United States in France where they won
one nil as the biggest victory of their
history so you did not you wanted to
avoid that and that's why I think
ultimately when you take 24 hours and
you reflect on the whales game it feels
like a loss even though it wasn't
how do you explain what happened
yesterday for Team USA
uh you explain it to the sports fan that
is not an avid soccer fan it was a tale
of two halves the first half Greg
peralter with his starting lineup and
the first half performance a plus no
doubt about it arguably the best
performance since he's been a manager
but here's the difference of what
happened in the second half Wales is a
one-trick pony and that pony is a six
foot five Center Ford by the name of key
for more they didn't start him and so
you knew if they were going to go down a
goal he's immediately coming off the
bench damn they didn't have plan B they
didn't have an idea on how to counter
key for more coming off the bench and
that I think is the most disappointing
aspect of the game is that tactically
they didn't make an adjustment but more
so I think the substitutions and the
Personnel coming out at halftime with
West McKinney battling an injury sergino
dest and McKinney both on yellows Dan
Greg burholter in the United States they
didn't do anything they kind of sat on
the fence and that's kind of what you
experienced in the second half what do
you expect on Friday against England
uh I expect the entire world to see and
and expect England to dominate and this
is where the United States often on the
men's side play at their best when
they're a complete underdog now Vegas is
not going to have them as huge underdogs
but you and I know what the story lines
are going to be England is always had a
chip on their shoulder for making sure
that the United States in this fourth
particular feel like the stepchild the
Americans love the English accent they
love what England does they want to be
England in the sport there's just so
many undertones of what it's going to
happen and that is not even on the field
where I think England has more talents
but the United States on the men's side
always thrive in the underdog they've
got to find a way to get a result and by
saying that I mean even if it's losing
by just one goal because gold
differential now with the 6-2 victory of
the English head over Iran now becomes
the tiebreaker you just can't lose the
game by a lot if you are going to lose
the game I think they should get a draw
if you ask me right now what's your
level of confidence one to ten with the
United States
six
maybe six and a half uh it's not
extremely confident because they're
young this is their first experience I
think it's extremely important Dan when
you look at the future of where this
team's gonna go and this being the
quote-unquote golden generation of
players the United States is hosting the
World Cup in 2026. this will be the
first time the United States men have
their best generation of players ever
developed
barely in their Prime and they're going
to be playing at home so you want to
have a positive experience at this world
cup you don't want to bomb out of the
World Cup you don't want to do what you
did in 1998 but I'm also not saying they
desperately need to get to the
quarterfinals either they've got to have
a positive result and a positive
experience that can come Black Friday
against England but I'm just not totally
confident that this team at the highest
of levels can score goals because quite
honestly with how the first half went
yesterday they should have had two or
three goals and they didn't create
enough quality chances yeah I wondered
if this team it it's just not their time
and but get that experience you look
down through history with teams that win
championships they usually have to go
through that losing period you know the
the Chicago Bulls with the Pistons the
Pistons with the Celtics in basketball
terminology and I I wondered if maybe
we're too young at this moment uh you
know Christian pulisic how much pressure
is on him in this and and exactly Dan
you're hitting the nail in the head
because Christian was part of he was the
young buck on the 2018 qualifying team
that failed to qualify for the World Cup
so he's already kind of shaped his
national team experience with negative
experiences and that's why for this
group with pulisic being the head of the
snake so to speak you need to have some
positive experience Christian was okay
yesterday I thought he was fantastic on
the goal we saw Christian of old but
then we've also saw some really bad set
piece delivery some key moments where
the final ball wasn't there that's why
my confidence go back to your initial
question of where my confidence level is
in the final third at the critical
moment the United States just hasn't
showed enough quality to against a
higher quality competition until they do
so my confidence level is going to
remain six six and a half and mainly
that's because Holistics need pulisic
needs to play at the highest of levels
to get there ESPN soccer analyst and
host Taylor twillman joining us how do
you explain Messi and Argentina loser
that is the second longest in the
history of the game it's the first time
they've lost to a FIFA ranked opponent
outside top 50 and God knows how many
years I I don't know how to explain it
there the the funny part is in in you
we're all part of this now in American
Sports with video review and instant
replay and all that Argentina did score
three goals that were called back dude
offside and one of them was ridiculous
so that's how quickly that game changed
Saudi Arabia deserves a ton of credit
for making life difficult
but in 2010 Spain lost their opening
game they won the World Cup they're the
only team to do so and in 1990 Diego
Maradona and Argentina lost the Cameroon
and got to the final I'm not counting
Argentina and Messi out but I'm not sure
I can quantify how they lost to Saudi
Arabia today we like bottom line winning
championships somebody made the
comparison one of my listeners Messi is
like Dan Marino
oh wow fantastic comparison I would
argue you tell me did Dan Marino ever
have a Supporting Cast that justified
winning Super Bowls
he got to one Super Bowl
felt like he had he he had good
receivers
but not great receivers right don't you
think they they punched above their
weight a little bit because of Dan
Marina yeah oh yeah absolutely I think I
think Dan Marino was 30 years ahead of
his time
yep I agree with you I also think Messi
is is an alien we've never seen anything
like it now they got to the 2014 World
Cup final mainly off the messy shoulders
and he carried him there ironically Dan
if you would have talked to me before
the World Cup started I would have said
this is Messi's best chance and they
laid an egg today so I it I to compare
him to Dan Marino's difficult because I
don't think Dan Marino's the best player
that we've ever seen in the NFL he was
before his time I agree with you that
Messi's the best thing we've ever seen
he's an alien but one match to one match
to win Taylor
yes give me the give me the best soccer
player you can pick one soccer player
I'm taking play I'm taking play
absolutely okay right now in this
generation because the argument as you
and I both know social media will take
it millions of ways Messi or Ronaldo I'm
taking Messi 100 out of 100 times you
don't like Ronaldo Ronaldo
yeah make sure you get that on social
media just so everyone comes after me
absolutely that's the only reason why
you did that
listen I I like when all those sure it's
fine but Messi's an alien will never see
anything like Messi again I promise you
that we will see another athletic
specimen like Cristiano Ronaldo we will
he may not be at the level that Ronaldo
is but my God Messi is something I've
never seen before
what's it like when they put the card in
front of you when you nothing better but
they call you over they call you over
like you're getting a yellow card you're
getting what's that like
yeah well Dale let me ask you did you
ever get you know a slip in in school
where like you were called out in front
of class and the teacher had to give you
a slip and you were like oh no now I'm
in trouble it's no different it's just
there's a split second where everything
puckers up and everything gets real
tight you're like is it yellow or red
I'm good I'm fine when it comes red then
you're like oh no what did I just do did
I do it and I did can you say anything
it's kind of fun can you argue your case
yeah but once the card shot there's no
video dude there's a little there's
actually video review now that can maybe
change it if it's egregious but usually
they don't but you could say anything
you want that referee's not all of a
sudden gonna go yeah you know what good
argument I'm gonna put the card back no
it's out once it's out you're in trouble
scariest atmosphere you ever played in
Ah that's a real good one World Cup
qualifier in Central America where
we're throwing water at me I thought
they were throwing objects and it was uh
urine feces and batteries
wow okay if you have to pick now listen
in this business now and being in the
media I it's not you know I I would
argue I've had bags of feces thrown at
me in different ways it's just it's
never really hit me
on the shoulder yeah it's usually on
social media to it's exactly it's a bag
of uh feces that's a tweet there but if
you were gonna pick you could have
batteries urine or feces thrown at you
while you're playing
yeah listen it's totally fine like I'm a
dad now I'll take a pack of urine any
day
and you know maybe I'm exhausted I could
use Alexa to answer your question though
to answer your question Borussia
Dortmund we played Germany in Dortmund
stadium and it's the yellow wall behind
the goal and it's over 30 000 fans just
behind the goal Dan I'm not going to
tell you how many times I had to change
my underwear before that game started
do you still have people who uh you know
four years ago they bring up your what
are we doing rant to you yeah of course
uh yeah it's I'm on Cameo and not one
would argue that I made uh 30 people's
day on that by the way they asked me to
do that on Valentine's Day just let that
simmer down I had many of people ask me
to do what are you doing wait is it is
it a breakout video a breakup video on
Valentine's Day wait what are we doing
what are we doing here
I just I I did it I played the game but
I kind of want to know the backstories
of why on Valentine's Day I was
requested more than any other day not
Christmas not New Year's Eve Valentine's
Day what are we doing are you gonna have
a meltdown if we don't advance
no no I won't have a meltdown that was a
I'm gonna have a meltdown because
Charles Barkley's actually figured out
his swing because the last time we
played Dan I think he lost
and you can text him this that I said
this I think he lost three and a half
dozens of golf balls at Boston Golf Club
you know what you know what helped him
cured him it's two new hits I don't care
what swing coach told him what to do he
got two new hips and boy he's uh good
for him I feel I feel for Chuck he
needed to fix that yes he did uh hey
great to talk to you again Taylor thanks
for joining us
yeah no problem my man be good that's
Taylor twillman the ESPN soccer analyst
and uh former member of the national
team